I want to jump to the story here which
uh it's in line with this it's from NBC
news they wrote on musk's Twitter users
looking to sell and trade child abuse
material are still easily found a review
conducted by NBC News found dozens of
accounts and hundreds of tweets claiming
to sell child sexual abuse material I
gotta stop right there and just say this
Elon Musk takes over Twitter and
immediately goes to task of cleaning
this stuff up for years Twitter allowed
and protected not only groomers but
active abusers of children I'd like to
point out that James Lindsay and I James
Lee got a permanent suspension for
calling out actual grooming I had two
tweets removed because I there was an
image of an adult human male showing
children graphic images and I said they
are grooming your kids and Twitter
locked my account and actually it's
right here look at this the the prop we
have from the Jack besobic gag says
Twitter suspends Tim Poole for calling
out groomers Tim goes off
now Elon Musk comes in and almost
immediately cleans up a good majority of
this all of a sudden now the corporate
press is like on Elon musk's Twitter
where was any of this reporting when
this was going on under the nose of Jack
Dorsey and Vegeta
conspiracy theory
and this is why
I think I I do want to stay focused on
on now as we get into the Twitter story
but I am not surprised that people hear
the Tate story and they say I don't
trust it and then because you act you
have the active protection from the
Press from the legal department from
International authorities defending the
stuff on Twitter protecting the Epstein
Client List and things like that this is
why people are just like I don't believe
it when they know what you don't like
the corporate press they go after you
with with the same things that you don't
like like when uh they went after Matt
Walsh saying he was a groomer and James
Lindsay and Lindsay too James Lindsay
went to a conference where he spoke in
it and I think you I think he spoke at
the same conference as Nikki Klein Nikki
Klein I'm pretty sure she was a member
of nixium right I believe so yeah and so
they are now trying they've been running
the smear campaign would say James
Lindsay comma a known associate of the
nixium sex cult they met at a conference
like it would be like you get like you
guys being associated it with me because
you're here talking to us about ideas
correct that's why it's just it's really
hard when the when this when the
corporate press comes out and the these
authorities come out and they're like
well you know Andrew Tate did these
things people's immediate reaction is BS
If he if he was actually doing this and
you cared you'd have gone after that
Client List and if you actually cared
you would have gone after the people on
Twitter is it James Lindsay's not saying
that he does these things where uh Tate
does
well so so James Lindsay's there's
videos of Tate saying he had women who
loved him working for him producing it
was on his website yes so I mean that's
the difference James Lindsay's like oh
let's talk about uh cultural Marxism and
that so that's not his brand
right I'm just saying that
NBC news right now is trying to accuse
musk of what what what Jack dorsey's
Twitter was doing 100 not even a
question and Elon Musk is trying to shut
it down yeah well number one musk
inherited a crime scene he inherited a
decades old problem and I used decade as
sort of a benchmark I'm sure I could go
back further but that was when the first
piece in the guardian that I've been
able to find uh there could be others
out there talking about the child sexual
abuse material problem on Twitter uh was
a decade ago so Elon Musk purchased a
platform that had a decades-old problem
and now uh the corporate press once
again first and foremost I'd like to
pull up every article that the corporate
media wrote about this issue on Twitter
specifically prior to Elon Musk
purchasing this platform how about every
article from like what was it salon and
the New York Times that have been
actively defending pedophilia or like
the the Ted Talk from that woman where
she actively defended it there was
recently uh what was it New Zealand is
is it New Zealand now that's that's not
they're using the word Maps they're
using the phrase Maps like yo Scotland
Scotland Scotland
these people are groomers it is obvious
what they're doing and why they're doing
it and they're they're using this now
against Elon Musk because accuse your
enemy of what you do they're projecting
yeah we saw the the cultural landscape
we saw the groundwork being laid this
this furthest larger kind of grooming
activity for a very long time and and
it's so it's so Insidious it's so
dishonest it's it's so insane that
there's corporate media Outlets
literally calling for the the
excusing a lot of this Behavior by
calling it minor attracted persons uh a
police department in Scotland usually
used that against a known pedophile
um so seeing this and also seeing you
know individuals like yoel Roth the
former head of trust and safety at
Twitter who literally wrote a thesis a
thesis um supporting children using
Grindr
um and now now finally the corporate
media has a problem with this kind of
behavior because Elon Musk is in charge
of Twitter that's both bullcrap they
were aiding and abetting it for such a
long time and this goes along with I I
don't know let me know what you think
but this goes along towards a larger
agenda trying to normalize a lot of this
sick Behavior I fully agree that's
exactly what I think it is I wish I had
better news for everyone
that's exactly what it is no I'm serious
because if they can make the world so
sick and depraved uh what Have We Become
as a society we won't fight back if we
won't fight for children we definitely
won't fight for our own Freedom under
tyranny I was talking to James Lindsay
at Turning Point USA and then we went up
on stage and James brought this up it
starts with drag queen Story Hour and
then when you come out and say drag is
an adult inherently sexualized
performance they go no no no these are
just people in costumes reading books
it's like it's like if they were just
like a fairy princess and you're like no
no no no no no drag is effectively
stripping and burlesque okay it's like
burlesque not a proof of kids but
they're only reading books then they
grab they graduate to
drag queen all ages drags you know all
ages drag show now they're actually
doing the burlesque but it's just it's a
dance show with costume change then you
get San Antonio sexual uh and in Florida
they did it too bringing kids out
talking openly and overtly about sex
simulating sexual activities because the
whole process from start to finish was
grooming yep then you have social media
promoting degenerate Behavior showing a
lot of outrageous content especially in
people's users user feeds especially on
Instagram of some of the most borderline
pornographic content that you could even
imagine and then you have of course porn
that's readily available free for
everyone as long as you have an internet
connection you could get to it and a lot
of children are getting it to it and
it's rewiring their brains in very
negative ways over sexualizing them
making sure that they could never have a
strong family unit and when you break
down the family unit you have more
people being victims you have more
people being picked off you have more
people being on their own and left in a
more vulnerable situation and I think
you know there's many layers to this and
we could keep compounding it and we
could keep connecting the dots but
there's a lot of freaking dots I know
people with uh kids in elementary school
who saw some text messages about these
young kids talking about being like in
polyamorous relationships I mean I guess
my question actually
I'm in a room with men
how do men feel about the world headed
in this
Direction because anti-human but what
I guess at a certain point
I do kind of wonder
when the men are going to do a thing and
I know that makes me not uh you know
feminist or whatever and I'm not um I
only am out here doing what I do because
there's
let me not get myself fully
if I if there were I don't want to be
doing this job
I don't want to be protecting women that
are being abused
um I want good men of the world to be
protecting these women but because there
aren't enough out here I have to be out
here I agree what are what are what are
men gonna do well well or maybe I'm
wrong I don't know this is like a
question that I haven't fully thought
through it's a good question the men in
this room Are The Men Who call out
Epstein okay and Luke of course longer
than I think the rest of us yeah shout
out to Luke I didn't know about all your
hard work before I came last time I'd
remember I didn't know and
I need that it was Furious seeing VH1
promote Epstein and everyone in the
alternative media screaming about it and
it wasn't Josh Jones it was a lot of
other people a lot of independent
journalists including also the Miami
Herald shout out to them they were one
of the few organizations out there Mike
cernovich and the Daily Mail
surprisingly one of the few
organizations that that first started to
actually talk about this in a very
serious way but first it was Independent
Media before anyone else I just want to
say I I was ragged on The Daily Mail
earlier because they're obsessed with
Meghan Markle and Princess was it Harry
or whatever but equally they would not
shut up about prince Andrew during the
Epstein stuff and I'm like that I like
so here's my point about the men it if
you look at the polls uh the polling Vox
found that like 45 of millennial men
vote Democrat and then like 55 percent
just shy 55 55 vote Republican whereas
for women it's about 70 Democrat and
like 28 Republican because there's like
some you know like green party stuff in
there
I I think you have half of these guys
who are weakened effeminate bottom of
the bell curve guys who will not stand
up defend the people they love and care
about they will not be masculine but I I
must admit as much as I have disdain for
these guys I have more disdain for the
system that tells them masculinity is
bad and and to to be ashamed of being
masculine and that's that's one of the
one of the things we see here so it's
interesting Phil about it just hit me
with a good Twitter comment he said
legal and local
legal and local what is it elaborate in
terms of event yeah that's the solution
legally local that's what I hope that's
what he was referencing to otherwise I'm
putting words in his mouth I think I
think one of the reasons that people
don't want to believe yeah anything
about Andrew Tate yeah is because this
message of opposing the machine plays
into a larger picture of the machine is
telling men not to be masculine which in
turn is resulting in men not protecting
women and children and the Machine is
telling is advocating for hardcore
degeneracy and so I think for a lot of
people I'm I'm not here to accuse or or
defend Andrew Tate but but I think what
I see from a lot of people in the chat
when they're split on this is yeah if
this guy at the very least is saying
exercise workout be strong be tough and
break from the machine the end result of
that puts a stop to a lot of this
whatever it is he's accused of doing you
know what I mean
sure so um so galane did a lot of nice
things too she was at a I mean you so
abusers like a serial killer isn't a
serial killer like 24 hours a day seven
days a week so I'm not saying that some
of the things yeah yeah you should work
out and eat right no no you should break
free from the machine and you should
um you know I'm not saying every man has
to be a masculine man because that's not
a thing that I believe but
I mean yes you should work out and eat
right you should break free from the
machine you should break free from The
Matrix or whatever you should be red
pill white pill past all that you know
but
um you should also not abuse people I
think a lot of the problem is a
consequence of what Luke was saying
about the family structure being
destroyed and a lot of people today a
lot of men today don't have father
figures and they're raised with the
government being their parent the
colleges being their parents uh they're
if they have a stay-at-home mom or dad
that that parent is out all the time so
they're kind of being raised by I think
mostly bad people but also when you're
not strong when you don't have a family
unit You're vulnerable and the Predator
class which is made up of a lot of
Psychopathic politicians and
billionaires out there preys on a lot of
individuals who can't defend themselves
who are not strong enough to do so or if
they are victimized they're not going to
be able to go to anybody because they
have no family member in order to
protect them or even report that they're
missing thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time